[Musica]
molti di voi ultimamente mi fermano per
strada dicendo mi so che ti da fastidio
però bla bla bla bla no non è vero
sfatiamo questo mito
non è vero che mi dà fastidio semi
fermate prestata dipende dalla
situazione dipende dal contesto socio
politico della giornata se io ho fatto
la spesa e mi vedete quelle buste del
cra in mano ma in giro non c'è nessuno è
solo da solo mi potete tranquillamente
fermare e in altri casi in cui si pone
il problema del rompimento di [ __ ]
per esempio che ne so quando sono al
ristorante giapponese con i miei amici
siamo lì che parliamo di cazzate come è
andata la giornata cosa stai facendo in
questo periodo
finiamo di mangiare ci alziamo tutti
quanti e andiamo a pagare poco prima di
andare alla cassa mi fermano due ragazzi
nel tavolo più lontano nell'angolo più
remoto del ristorante che tra l'altro
dire ragazzi è molto generoso perchè
avranno avuto 40 anni probabilmente
credo e dopo la prima domanda avevo già
capito che sarebbe andata a [ __ ] la
serata perché quella domanda è stata tu
sei quello che fa video su youtube
giusto e poi boh
siamo finiti all'inferno questi ragazzi
erano due io ho notato che mentre uno mi
faceva delle domande l'altro si
nascondeva quasi con la mano guardando
il piatto di ravioli al vapore che stava
lanciando ignorandolo bellamente e io
comunque mi fermo e con un sorriso
imbarazzato rispondo sì e lui continua
dicendo mi quindi tu sei quello che fa
recensioni di videogiochi
io gli stavo morendo che imbarazzo cosa
ti rispondo non lo so
no non solo c'è sempre o meno nel senso
che ho un canale però non è che faccio
il recente cose ma che va che domani ma
per ma scusami io mi stavo spezzando le
gengive da quanti i denti stavo
stringendo da quel momento di imbarazzo
e quindi me la sono voluta a giocare
veloce dicendogli è più o meno e allora
non mi fa la domanda fatidica mi guardi
mi dice ma scusa tu non sei lo sci e lo
ship e io sul meglio cento a sorella ma
cosa vuol dire c'è perché mi hai fermato
se non sai chi sono e il suo amico che
guardando i ravioli gli dice senza
alzare lo sguardo dice no io toby aiuto
agli ottavi gli ochhi me la stessa cosa
ma non ha scudato perché
se non sai chi sono perché lo sono in
questo momento come successo che
diventare famosi su youtube
mi avrebbe fatto ritrovare in un
ristorante giapponese a dire no non sono
io sim e non sapere cosa fare cosa
ma cosa vuol dire come soffino quale
congiunzione astrale mi ha portato ad
essere in questo momento qui e io avevo
capito tutto avevo capito che era
l'altro che mi aveva riconosciuto e l'ha
detto al suo amico che non sapeva chi
fossi e allora per fare lo scherzo né
best friend mi ha affermato dicendomi tu
sei quello che fa le recensioni di
videogiochi ma allora quindi se proprio
dovete fermarmi fate come hanno fatto
con john lennon mi fermai dice ciao
seggiolino sì e mi sparato un colpo nel
petto e finisce lì almeno mi risparmio
l'imbarazzo porca [ __ ]
[Musica]